open your minds word Smiths we're
talking about the word perceive ah it's
one of those E before I words some of
the hardest to spell in English perceive
is a verb this verb means to notice
something you might also know it from
its noun form perception
perception it's a non-specific way of
saying that your senses are picking
something up you can perceive sights
smells tastes sounds feelings perception
perceiving covers all of that so this
comes from Latin all of it does uh
because of the E before I thing in the
verb form I think it's a little easier
to break it down as a noun so let's look
at perception so per is a prefix that
means completely or
through uh the sept part comes from Capa
which you might also see as CA capap PT
it means to grasp to grab and I N is a
noun forming suffix right an ending that
turns other words into nouns so a
perception is when you grasp something
completely when you understand it let's
take 10 seconds and come up with some
similar words that contain these
elements per and capped and I N 3 2 1
Let's
[Music]
J
okay here's some I came up with
pervasive an adjective meaning
everywhere per means through and vad
means to go compare the word invade
right to go in uh so something that's
pervasive has completely gone through a
community pervasive influence pervasive
illness pervasive Trends capture a verb
meaning to grab to take by force this is
probably as close a a direct English
translation as you can get of the Latin
verb
cap reception a noun meaning getting
something receiving a thing you might
have bad reception in the dining room
because the Wi-Fi is weak there or
reception can mean a formal event like a
wedding reception the thing you are
receiving is partygoers you are
welcoming them to celebrate with you
let's use perception and perceive in a
couple of sentences thanks to his Keen
powers of perception Walter saw that the
BR was about to collapse and kept
everyone away he saw it he noticed it
right he was he he looked at the bridge
and he was like that structural beam
exhibits signs of metal fatigue good eye
Walter thanks for saving lives let's
let's do another one using her psychic
powers Jade perceived VI before he
entered the room right she's sensing him
with in this case her psychic powers and
of course another term for psychic
powers is extra sensory perception H
what we used to call the sixth sense
that's right I'm putting more content in
the outro try to stop me oh right I
forgot I cannot be stopped but you can't
either because you can learn anything
David out